this video is sponsored by raycon so I
recently discovered that I am quickly
running out of space for all of this
manga shelves are bending and this thing
could crumble at any second basically I
need space but it got me wondering I've
got a lot of manga many of you don't
know what series I own or what I have
yet to read and given I'm in need of a
new series review I want you guys to
choose so basically if you see a series
you'd like me to cover in my collection
today leave your vote in the comments
down below but remember you can only
choose one this is your chance to have
your voice heard and have your favorite
manga reviewed so yeah uh let's dive
okay well actually I feel like this is a
little too cramped for what I want to do
here everything might fall if I touch it
so let's move to a safer location
that's better uh so basically right uh
for me to consider my collection a
library I'm supposed to according to
google have 1 000 manga or books
so I have no idea how many manga I have
back here but it's quite a few so I'm
going to be keeping a rolling tally on
how many manga copies I have as I go
through each individual series uh so
yeah let's kick things off with
last time on Dragon Ball Z for the
uninitiated this is Dragon Ball and it's
in terms of volumes I think there's like
90 volumes here I counted before this I
think it's it's 90. yes yeah okay it's
90. there's 90 volumes here of different
descriptions whether it be the colored
manga the viz bigs you got the
re-release with new modern art I say
Modern Art of Akira Toriyama you got
some collector books and all that kind
of stuff you got some classic copies of
Dragon Ball super uh I have all of them
Olive Dragon yeah they're over here all
the Dragon Ball super I think it also
happens to be my very first manga is
here can you tell which one of these are
my first ones they're like all Sun
bleached and they were some of the first
manga I ever read in my life so yeah
this is where it all started humble
beginnings but I think maybe the most
interesting part of my entire collection
is actually in this and they come with
these
now this is sort of unconventional so I
decided to one day see if I could
purchase a copy of Shonen jump from the
1980s and in these copies of Shonen Jump
you actually get to see
the original release of I think Goku vs
Vegeta literally the very first time
they ever fought and it's like really
big too
kind of cool
but yeah I have uh the different
different parts of that fight just all
collected I hope to one day have all of
them collected I think that'd be pretty
cool
cut all the stuff
that's Dragon Ball that's 90 so far
strong Star right next
assassination classroom this is a
typical case of judging a book by its
cover I just really like the the cover
of the very first volume like never pick
the button guys never picked
yeah I just like the cover it's just
really simple and I heard someone
describe a scene from it and it sounded
interesting I haven't read it now
normally with these reviews or normally
with this channel I collect the manga
that either I am currently reading or
will read in the future so this is an
example of the latter I'm probably going
to end up reviewing this at some stage
but I don't know do you guys want me to
read assassination classroom comment
down below if you do I heard it's
supposed to be pretty good so yeah
assassination classroom
IQ is an example of a series that is
quite long that is also very difficult
to uh to collect I think I'm missing a
few volume yeah I'm missing volumes 10.
there are other sports manga that you'll
see in this in this video that I have
but I just don't have all of it
now I do want to again read a high Q
I've never read it but I have watched
the first couple of episodes and I
really like the idea behind the series
um but as Sports manga go I'm not a huge
Aficionado I don't read a lot of sports
manga but I want to get into it so is
haikyu good yes
Hunter Hunter is a great series uh yeah
so this is one of the mangas that I
actually bought specifically for the
purposes of review and that review is
out so if you want to watch that review
uh linking
somewhere on my Channel watch it there
um yeah so uh Hunter Hunter was just one
of those stories that like I knew about
for a very long time and I really wanted
to check it out and I found the perfect
excuse to when I started reviewing other
series than Dragon Ball so with Hunter
Hunter you have a story written by a guy
that feels like it devolves into madness
towards the end and some people love
that some people don't like it most
people do
um I thought it was a little dark but
it's dark in a really good way check it
out I highly recommend it
yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor the holidays
are honest and with that
kind of what to buy our loved ones
thankfully Ray
are the way to go
the podcast while working but they're
just as great for exercising and walking
your dogs that versatility is why
everyone needs raycon and they're a
wonderful option for this gift-giving
season regardless of whether you pick up
their earbuds headphones or speakers
they offer premium sound useful features
and an almost custom comfortable fit
best of all some offerings have up to 54
hours of battery life while they sound
fantastic what really makes them
attractive this season is their price at
half the price of other premium audio
Brands they're a fantastic option for
those looking to save money if you've
got a bunch of people to buy for raycons
Holiday bundles are great and offer 30
off the stay fit bundles got everything
you need for those who love to work out
at home and out and about so click the
link in the description box or go to buy
recon.com forward slash not Mark and use
code early BF to get 20 off site white
or save even bigger and get 30 off
raycon's exclusive holiday bundles there
will also be different deals coming
throughout the season and I'll try to
keep the description box updated with
the latest offers but just so you know
you can always go to buy raycon.com
forward slash not Mark to get the best
deals available on raycon
okay this video is like way more uh
physically demanding than I thought it
was going to be
um I built this really nice set do you
like it I like it
um so uh
oh god oh uh very quickly in case you
guys wanted to request something like
Gintama or Hajime no ippo while I would
love to cover series like this at the
moment these stories aren't licensed in
English and so don't have an official
English manga release as a general rule
of thumb my channel doesn't review or
cover material that needs to be obtained
illegally to digest now this obviously
isn't to discredit Fan translations as
they're very talented I'm just trying to
navigate illegal Minefield okay back to
the video
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is
wow
weirdly genius
so like oh it's upside down I was
embarrassing Iraqi is like one of those
mangaka that doesn't feel like a mangaka
if that makes any sense now from my
experience going through uh different
reviews I like to delve into the person
behind each manga and with Iraqi this
was kind of interesting because he
actually wrote his own book on how to
write manga or at least how he learned
to write manga it was kind of
Illuminating because I was able to you
know appreciate the Artistry and the
story behind JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
when I was reviewing it a little better
because I could sort of see him talking
about that very experience
um now I went into JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure with a sort of less than
reverence uh concerning the actual
material because I actually came into it
via the anime which I didn't so much
enjoy but when I picked up the manga I
honestly God thought it was a much
better experience uh like the artwork in
this is actually insanely good even from
the gecko but it like it gets that much
better as it goes on
um when it comes to different stories is
I liked the idea of part three a lot
um and it was way more fun than I
thought it was going to be Joseph is my
favorite Joe star I don't think this is
the full collection now when I bought it
all of this was out and there wasn't any
more but I think there's more right now
so I'll probably added this collection
uh where we are where are we at now uh
with the tally editor
oh
next
foreign
that is in the running for the best
Manga of all time you know what actually
I'm gonna say it it's the best Manga of
all time and not even from a literary
standpoint okay berserk 10 out of 10.
when the series came to volume 41 uh
they made a special release for it in
commemoration of Quintero Miura so I
decided to pick that one up so this is
probably out there as one of my favorite
purchases in my collection
um it's volume 41 and yeah
rip
Akira when it comes to displaying my
manga I don't normally keep them inside
these boxes shows like Dragon Ball
um One Piece you'll see later uh Naruto
bleach these are all series of come
inside boxes and most of them I don't
keep them in the box for display
purposes Akira I picked up ages ago I
still haven't read it but I will always
display it in this box because look how
cool it is oh
that should be illegal okay so look
the actual books inside there look
really pretty look how look how pretty
right
yeah I don't know apparently the uh the
movie itself cuts out this middle part
of it which is like most of the story so
I'm interested in actually reading this
one day and doing it alongside a movie
review for the series because it's up
there like Berserkers like one of the
granddaddies of manga in general so I'm
actually really excited to read this one
day so yeah hope it's good
foreign
is a weird one for me because I grew up
with a lot of these films and the first
real uh production from Japan that I saw
as like a feature film that was worthy
of getting some sort of notoriety or
award in the west was Spirited Away
um but it's very difficult to review
those stories on YouTube for copyright
purposes so I I Really Wanna I have a
lot to say about Studio Ghibli and one
of the actual stories from Studio Ghibli
that I would be very interested in
Reading would be uh nausicaa the Valley
of the wind and that's because Hayao
Miyazaki actually went out of his way to
write a very substantial manga
concerning the actual story in the film
I don't know if there's more material in
this uh similar to how there was more
material in Akira's original version
that was omitted from the film maybe
maybe that is the case but I'd be very
interested to see Haya miyazaki's take
on the manga genre and how he would
approach it uh Princess mononosuke uh
that's just one of those you know it's
an art book I love it I love that film
it's really cool
um but yeah I want to get some more
Studio Ghibli stuff but this is just
sort of the beginning
I've got to show you what this one is
earlier this year I started collecting a
series because
um it was a big part of my childhood and
there were some
um not so great news that came from it
but
I've been trying to collect it for a
very long time
um and really what hold me back is how
[ __ ] hard it is to get into these
packages no it's really hard
a group
[ __ ]
three knife
I got it
um it's Yu-Gi-Oh
um Yugioh was like one of the first
franchises I ever was able to engage
with with friends outside of Pokemon and
Digimon it's sort of in that same
ballpark and
um I really want to review this one day
I just don't have
enough of it it's really hard to get
nowadays I'm not sure if they're in
print anymore but uh yeah if anyone out
there knows where I can get some of
these in English preferably
um yeah hit me up let me know
have you ever read a manga that before
you read it sort of came with like this
um socially imposed warning label
good night pun pun
is a manga that I had been told to and I
quote not read because it would give me
depression
um I don't know how true that is but uh
I read I want to say
the first five chapters of it and then
had to move on with work I don't
actually read a lot of manga in my spare
time believe it or not anymore it's just
sort of become my job now but uh yeah it
is a really weird story
um it's given me the impression that it
gets even weirder and maybe even very
dark uh so yeah this would be maybe an
interesting one to do a short video on
for Halloween next year I don't know
maybe something like that
thank you
boy fire one of the most consistently
requested stories for me to review
Pokemon Adventures
I don't know
I've never read it I looked at a few
pages from it it's not the story from
the anime or I'm it might be from the
games uh the Pokemon you can see them in
the balls and it looks like they're
going off of very old designs and so
maybe I if you guys want me to read if I
mean [ __ ] I I'll read it but uh it's
always difficult to review stories that
don't have like a companion anime for
which to uh cut to for you know context
for you guys making uh videos using only
manga imagery is extremely taxing and
you know it's not really that
interesting to look at at least not
without tremendous effort from editor
Stan so yeah Pokemon Adventures uh I
don't know if it's good or not but
judging by the amount of people asking
me to review it it might be pretty good
yes
this is a Full Metal Alchemist
now I have a couple of other volumes
that come with this but they're kind of
in the miscellaneous category but in the
category of Full Metal Alchemist this is
my full collection
um I have the entire series it's waiting
and ready to go did It win some award
recently where it got like best Manga
overall or something like that
um yeah I've never read anything by the
mangaka herself that Drew this and wrote
it but yeah it's up there consistently
it's one of the best of all time so I'd
be interested to see it because I've
only seen I saw the anime but there's
two anime it was the first one I saw it
up until that episode with the Chimera
child monster thing the bird monster is
that the wrong show I've seen very
little of it I know the two main
characters the kid in the giant suit of
armor and the brother
I don't know their names
Full Metal Alchemist
s
slam dunk getting the full collection of
Slam Dunk is like throwing
50 consecutive shots from half court and
swishing them all because I have and I
kid you not tried for over a year and a
half to find volume volume 19.
volume 19 doesn't exist on Planet Earth
for a reasonable amount of money and I
refuse to start this series Without
volume 19. what happens in volume 19
is it amazing
it must be because it doesn't exist on
[ __ ] planet Earth anymore
slam dunk
Makoto shinkai
um I don't know why I have a silent
voice in here with Makoto shinkai I
think it might be because then the
silent Voice come out like right before
or after your name and it was like the
big conversation online about like oh
this is better and that's worse and I
love mitsuha that's a really great story
but apparently the manga is different so
I just had to buy the manga um and
there's two versions of it there's like
this really thick one down here and
there's this collection up here
um outside of that Makoto shinkai Makoto
shinkai is not the person that wrote a
silent voice let that be completely
clear here
but it's in that same area for me
outside of that story a Southern Voice
makoro shinkai has written a bunch of
different stories and there are some
light novels in here there are some
manga versions of your name
um a garden of words
um weathering with you actually a little
peek behind the curtain the movie your
name has a massive significance in my
life and I have to at some point make a
video for it I I have to if I never make
a video about your name that movie that
animated Masterpiece I have failed
so don't let me forget about that
review on your name absolutely has to
come and I'll probably cry okay
death note's good
read Death Note
punch man oh It's gotta be one of my
favorite manga Following season one I
bought as much of the series as I
possibly could I didn't read ahead
because I like I'm sure many of you out
there were waiting for season two and I
ended up waiting for way too long and I
forgot about the series I ended up
watching eventually season two when it
did come out I thought it was okay the
best thing about that right everyone
talked about that season is like oh it's
not as good as season one because the
animation isn't as good aware that's
right okay the animation isn't this good
but that's because the animation in
season one is like maybe the best
animated series of Television ever so
with season two what I liked about one
punch man season 2 was how good I found
the characters to be and that's all back
to the manga
I really and ah I mean this really wanna
review this series I have not read past
the boros fight which is the end of
season one so there's actually material
in this that I have actually seen in
anime that I haven't read in the manga
yet so everything after was covered in
the anime I have no idea what comes I'm
very excited to see more from this story
um like legitimately this is like one of
the series I'm most excited to see in
the future so yeah one punch man
mob psycho 100 is one of those shows
that I decided not to watch because I
was watching uh
wood punch man
um everyone says mob cycle is supposed
to be really good so I bought the manga
in anticipation of one day reviewing it
and I haven't yet uh done that so
um yeah tell me to review this and I
will yeah Maps like a 100.
foreign
why do you have season was it box set
one and box set one again
um
I'm gonna tell you the truth I
accidentally bought two and then made
plans to release this in a video saying
oh yeah if you could comment your name
or whatever and uh I'll give you the
thing but that sounded kind of cringe so
instead I just did the even worse thing
just kept it and now I can't return it
so
yeah uh maybe when I review thousand
year blood War or something I'll yeah
I'll make a competition yeah whoever
wins can take this home or whatever yeah
all right yeah bleach uh I reviewed it
it was really good
um it's not done yet it's still ongoing
people really don't like full bring I
don't get it it's for me at least the
best part of the story so far that I've
read from the beginning to the end of
fulbring like it's just it's so up my
alley I understand why some people don't
like it but I don't understand the
negativity and hatred some people have
for it it's manga it's chill out
bleach
akuman
it's a manga about making manga I read
the first volume
see I don't ever have enough time to
read the entire series I kind of I read
the first volume I'm like oh I'll
definitely make the review about this
Sunday but the dangerous thing about
what I do is I'll conflate what I want
to read
Bakuman but I also need to review things
that other people in the global
Zeitgeist will want to watch because
that's how I make a living there's a
timing aspect to it I might review one
punch man
um next year but that doesn't mean that
I didn't want to review it last year
it's just I have to review it when it
makes sense to review it because that's
when people are gonna be looking it up I
don't know how I'm going to review
Bakuman in the future bakama is like one
of those manga in my collection that
could be trapped in the shadow realm
forever
um unless it gets a re-release or
there's some hype surrounding it that
might come about who knows um but yeah
back of mine would like to review this
I don't know how I can in the future but
yeah
Jujutsu Kaizen
when I say that this manga makes me feel
old
I mean it so
I have become with regards this
particular Story the guy that has no
idea what the [ __ ] Jujitsu Kaizen is
because my job requires me to always be
working to always be making stuff
I've never gotten around to enjoy
anything in the last three years apart
from like some stuff that I had already
known about or seemed like Attack on
Titan or whatever so
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
has arrived established itself and
become one of the biggest and most
highest selling manga of all time
all the while I have no idea what it's
about
is it a Punch Kick manga I I Jiu Jitsu
it boobs
I might review it
gotta give myself to you yeah we're
flying on the freeway at night
I only got chainsaw man chainsaw man all
right
chainsaw man so this chainsaw fellow is
uh taking the World by storm right now
and just as well earlier this year I
wrote a review on chainsaw man and it is
just as good as everyone says it is at
least I think so
um it's got a really interesting art
style a really refreshing spin on the
comedic aspects of uh this Shonen genre
if you could even call it that it's sort
of an evolution of Shonen if you will so
it's a very cool concept for a story it
deals with some really interesting
themes and it does achieve actually if
someone in uh the comment section ever
doesn't like a video of mine they'll say
something like he's never addressed the
themes of this of the story and like
you're right I never addressed this
specific theme of this story that you
like and you think that's the reason why
I didn't like it that is not true
themes on their own are just ideas and
depending on the context the idea is
presented in it could be good and it
could be bad so for example avatar The
Last Airbender the movie
has themes
of coming of age taking responsibility
friendship all that jazz these
I think you might agree are good themes
but the movie's dog [ __ ]
so stuck
fair enough if you disagree with my
review but can we please stop saying
that I don't understand the themes of
the thing
of a show doesn't make the show Good
the story does
all right rant over yeah uh so this is
chainsaw man and Fire Punch I haven't
read fire punch people say fire punch is
good um but yeah chainsaw mine highly
recommended watch it read it
put it in your face makima
Attack on Titan is
I'm gonna say it a brilliant manga
because even if you don't like the
ending I personally liked the original
ending that was there
um I haven't seen the revised ending
there was like a half chapter or like
special chapter to like you know bookend
the whole series I never read that so I
don't know how it progresses after that
fact but yeah Attack on Titan is like
one of those series that like it's all
about the journey not the destination
it's delivered for me I think some of
the highest highs I've ever experienced
when reading a story I've never been so
physically involved and excited when
reading a story so feverishly turning
Pages just to see how this impossible
scenario will resolve itself with our
heroes coming out on top it is insanely
well written and I really love it and
it's for that reason I rolled an almost
three hour long review that I uploaded
and don't get paid for because the last
three minutes of the video is a cover of
a song that's used in that series and
they get all the money but I didn't take
it down because I'm that proud of that
video that is easily the best video I've
ever written and it is the view and the
views reflect that so if you haven't
seen that video and do like Attack on
Titan check it out one thing I will say
though the Colossal Edition
is [ __ ]
not because a I don't like reading big
versions of things I actually prefer it
all of the [ __ ] that I have here would
be big if I could get it but they always
like like it's always this like [ __ ]
small stuff right I I get it it's easier
to produce it's more cost effective I
get it but
Jesus this
is awful okay
I haven't touched this yet
I haven't opened so much to single page
but already it's like scoffed along the
edges whatever the opposite of the
berserk leather-bound Mammoth pieces
were this is that this is trash
great story
trash binding
attacking Titan
Pluto 20th century boys Monster urasawa
this is one of the most highly respected
manga authors of all time and
I've read one of these series Pluto
it is such an interesting
different and exciting way of writing
and drawing stories I can clearly see a
lot of like modern day inspiration uh
coming from this I much like how I feel
about Bakuman really would love to
review some of these stories at some
point but
I just don't know if that time will ever
come if it has that same mainstream
appeal that other uh shows have like Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen which I'm not against
reviewing but
um I would very much like to see more of
something like this out in the global
Zeitgeist
um and who knows maybe I'll make it
anyway but it would be more beneficial
at least an easier decision to make if
uh more people knew about this author
and um knew about this artist so
yeah
can I see me
Demon Slayer uh same situation as Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen I show that sort of showed
up blew up and I don't know anything
about being who I am
with respect
the Demon Slayer um as a person who
lives in planet Earth is sort of like a
nuclear explosion going off next door
and you being oblivious to it I don't
know what this story is
but everyone seems to love it so if you
would want me to read Demon Slayer and
maybe review it someday let me know
because if I'd
Demon Slayer
okay my sweet little T M nuggets were
almost there only a few more series left
and one of them is Parasite
parasite's good I really liked parasite
I really like the anime I've never read
the Manga but I've only ever opened it
once or twice and if I have seen the
series
um don't really intend on reviewing it
whenever I watch something that I really
really like especially nowadays with the
industry that I'm in and that I'm trying
to get into I really want to support the
official release in every capacity that
I can I hope that's evident by the sheer
volume of manga that I have no pun
intended the amount of manga that I have
is directly proportional to like the
amount of support that I want to give
the artists and the companies that
Supply us with this stuff because I
genuinely do want to pay for it and I
Don't Want To Do Wrong by them parasite
is such an example I loved the anime in
this and open up the manga the artwork
seems kind of Hit or Miss and I'm not
sure how that would uh impact me if I
was to read the entire series I've only
read a chapter or two and really was
just to kind of get a taste of what it's
like the paneling seems quite boxy if I
can if I remember correctly
um it just seems kind of flat no uh that
might be a bad example here but the
artwork seems
much more engaging
in the anime but the story itself plays
with some kind of cool philosophical
ideas and you know some horror it's
pretty good I recommend I definitely
recommend watching the series
um but if you want to pick up the manga
do it uh it's really good
spy X family
everyone seems to like this
um I haven't seen it shakar I don't
watch TV apparently is uh well I'm sure
most of you are saying right now
um so yeah spikes family looks cool
looks interesting I read the first
chapter um I think when it came out
actually but uh yeah Spike's family very
good I'll read it if you guys want me to
don't let this fool you a collection
of my hero Academia
with this many repeat additions
employees that I'm a massive fan of the
series I watched the anime and really
liked it I have not read a single
chapter of the manga I stopped watching
the anime
[ __ ] what chapter what's the
corresponder whatever the [ __ ]
episode was about the million yeah if
you yeah the million episode the one
that was like really good I mean I
stopped watching there because I was
like okay I have to review this series
someday and I think it might be better
if I don't actually know what's gonna
happen after this so yeah
I have watched up until that point
whatever that is in the manga yeah so
maybe someday I'll review
um my her Academia I think it does the
hero's journey really well and it does a
lot of core things that make Shonen jump
really endearing and fun extreme new so
yeah my hero Academia
junji Ito
so the junji Ito collection is a series
of short stories written by the author
janji Ito himself he's a manga artist
that specializes in horror fiction and I
haven't read a single uh chapter of his
material and that's by Design there's a
fantastic video written about Genji Ito
and his stories by super eye patch wolf
if you haven't seen it check it out it's
fantastic but pretty much off the back
of watching that video I went on to
Amazon where I get most of the stuff and
I just bought everything from Genji Ito
in the hopes that someday on a Halloween
or some corresponding holiday that might
make or make befitting to review it I
would review the like some stories from
it because I think there's something
genuinely interesting about his approach
to horror that uh at least was conveyed
in that video by super eye patch wolf
and I hope to get some raw Impressions
out of these books at some point because
they look fantastic
everything I know about story that I've
used in my reviews that I've used
anywhere that I appear online have
either come from my own lived
experiences have come from videos that I
have watched myself on YouTube or
they are contained in the books that you
see here today
I've read all of these some of these are
art books where I like to study a bit of
you know how to draw different shapes
and body types and everything from the
physical of the musculature all the way
to even like how how how fat is
distributed like I mean it's all this is
really interesting
um there's the animators handbook
there's uh paneling and composition in
Western Comics there's Hayao miyazaki's
book Turning Point there's another
version there's another part to that
series that I haven't read yet but I
absolutely will get around to there's
some art books again as I said but the
best ones I think and the ones that I
think have paid dividends for me
personally are these books
um Story by Robert McKee and if you're
into so if you're into like reviewing
material and want to get better at it
um Robert McKee has some very good books
on it specifically this one and yeah
it's like you know it just goes into
pretty much everything you need to know
um in detail but this is more of
advanced one if you want more of an
entry level one
um creating character arcs by uh km
Wyland uh it's a super easy read it's
Baba's first character Arc understanding
thing and it makes everything sound so
much more simplified and easy to
understand
um so yeah creating character arcs
um there's the art of dramatic writing
and this is a bit more involved I
haven't used it as much but I have used
it and it's given me a lot of insight
into different things
um John truby the anatomy of story for
those of you out there that might think
that titled the anatomy of story sounds
familiar
um I have a series on my channel called
the anatomy of anime and it's actually
inspired by this very book and I learned
a lot from this book it's a great book
and again like all the other ones here
can teach you a lot about how to write a
good story and what goes into making a
good story
and then finally there's John York into
the woods again it's again focuses on
more dramatic stuff and breaks down
difficult to understand Concepts into
easy to understand Frameworks and so
yeah if you are interested in getting
the storytelling I couldn't recommend
these ones more
Naruto is
I'm going to share a little bit of like
behind the Curt aspects of my channel
there are elements of Shonen that I
really like and there are really famous
stories from shown in history that are
famous and are held in such a high
regard regarding Nostalgia
um and normally there is a discrepancy
between the quality versus
um you know how people are claiming the
series to be Naruto was one of the
series one of the few series that I've
actually Revisited that is as good as
people are claiming it to be I think
um I think there's a really interesting
uh aspect of the story that's sort of
explored with the likes of Naruto
specifically being sort of an analog for
um being sort of analog for Kishimoto
himself uh I caught on that in the first
video I made on Naruto but yeah overall
Naruto is like a really great series
it's really endearing the first the main
character importantly so because the
series is titled Naruto uh he's
fantastic he's really good and the
series itself has a lot of Personality
that I really enjoyed it loses itself in
places
um it has some questionable ideas
um but I think it overall sticks to
landing and I you know I found it very
fun
oh yeah there's like some miscellaneous
stuff here that I'm not going to really
include in this video properly but
there's like Blue Exorcist a single
edition of that there's dead man
Wonderland these are all copies of like
manga like I bought right before hopping
on a plane just so I didn't have to like
twiddle my thumbs and just do whatever
I've got a few uh
is it blue
oh it's a light novel okay
um yeah and I also I I have accidentally
in the past purchased French editions of
Death Note so
um fromage I can't speak French also
this just came in the post blame so add
one to the tally
one piece
um in 100 pieces there are 100 volumes
of One Piece right here and let me tell
you
um as a Creator going in to review one
piece it was sort of sort of
nerve-wracking because it was the first
series I actually delved into properly
where I was exploring something other
than Dragon Ball for a long period of
time and it was fortunate for me that it
worked out but I think more so it was
that I was really worried that I wasn't
going to uh receive the series in my
mind as people wanted me to and I know
that shouldn't be a concern but it is
always when you're a Creator and that's
why it's kind of difficult to hear it
when people are saying things like oh
you don't understand all that kind of
stuff because genuinely when I make a
review I'm trying to be as honest and
good faith in my interpretation of the
material as I possibly can be one piece
was amazing from the start and continued
to be so all the way throughout
if there's any series out of this entire
collection of mine that I've shown today
that I would recommend for you
um there's two properties berserk and
one piece those are incredible stories
and they need to be seen and experienced
in order to be believed the one piece is
real
I'd like to thank everyone for watching
um if you would like to leave a comment
down below which of these series you
would like me to review in the future
please do that
um I'll be checking the comments
um so yeah
thanks for watching see you all next
time
Mark out